[Music]
foreign so man on the journey to uh to
islam
swearing man that's something so
normalizing today's society what do you
guys think
yeah yeah 100
it's uh i would say it's really big in
even humor today it's like it's hard to
be funny without being profane or or
swearing
but i could speak about this
all
day all day long but little do y'all
know watching and tuning in
that islam
has serious
ramifications from allah for swearing
it's not a joke
profanity back butting all the like so
uh inshallah today we'll go dive deeper
into that
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
did you get away on home.com
take it away man you said you could talk
all day man
oh about profanity yeah
yeah yeah you gotta you gotta walk the
walk bro if you're gonna talk to talk
okay so
profanity
it's one of those things that we grow up
with
um i'm gonna speak for especially people
who grew up non-muslim
and then they reverted
but i didn't grow up in the best
areas i grew up in very
i don't even want to speak badly about
them but there was a
lot of cursing
involved in these environments
and when you go around that that's where
you adapt or that's what you adopt i
should say that's what you it becomes
your way of speaking
you know like
patterns or we're creatures of behavior
so we adopt different patterns of
behavior as we
go on living in life speaking
is no different so when you speak and
you start cursing
it's just it's a program that's just
it's been already programmed into you
and it's not something that you
programmed yourself because if you guys
listen to someone cursing
and then you guys listen to someone not
cursing like you wouldn't want to
actively speak like the person who's
cursing because it just
not only do they keep repeating the same
words over and over and over and over
again but it it kind of just
it destroys all the momentum and power
that they have like
sometimes
the curse word
gives
it gives attention like you know like if
someone's kind of like dazing off in
their head they're thinking about this
this and that and someone says the curse
word just like one curse would they
haven't cursed at all but they say one
curse word it sucks for allah
it brings your attention back you're
like oh damn like body just cursed
you know but if the person's just
cursing a storm
it's vulgar
ain't nothing ain't normally to it and
something that i was speaking about
fired
a long time ago is that when we curse
if we allow ourselves to curse it's a
very
uh unmindful thing
you you become less present
and it's just kind of like you're on
autopilot versus like when
if you make the uh if you make it that
priority like look i'm not going curse
i'm not going curse it's like you still
want to curse because it's it's a
pattern of behavior so it's a program
that's trying to run itself
but you are
you're actively holding back and you
you're being mindful and seeing when
that feeling to curse comes up and it's
it's
it's a it's a crazy thing that's all i'm
going to say it's a crazy thing
man
you you are the leader
you are the the emir of the podcast bro
come on now
but
pertaining to one who said bro do you
have anything that you can relate to or
bring from your personal life journey
any experiences
yeah yeah so i mean this is basically
something that everyone has to go
through it's another just
um part of living in the west living
with the non-muslims uh i remember a
time when even when in cartoons like
there was no swearing like nothing and
now in cartoons like there is just like
profanity and like like sexual innuendos
and like all this weird stuff bro and
it's just uh this kind of regression of
society and people think it's like
since they're moving forward in time
they're progressing they don't realize
that they could easily easily be
regressing in their beliefs and the
morality and they're in their ways and
unfortunately as people have moved away
from religion and more towards just
doing whatever they want
um swearing and all these really really
dirty jokes have become really really
big and i challenge you guys to go find
one like
stand-up comic who just never swears
because a lot of the times wearing is
just a part of the act
so
swearing is just one of those things
it's like it's ingrained into society
and people have you know a hard time not
doing it if you work in construction
you're going to hear all the time um
certain workplaces
although it's supposed to be
professionals like it's you're gonna
hear
us swearing all the time it's
unfortunate um another example would be
in school a lot of people even when they
grow up with like really
tight-knit respectful respected families
uh they don't swear and then they go to
school and then they hear their friends
swearing and then they start swearing
when they're with that group of friends
so when they're home they don't say
anything but when they're with a group
of friends
they're just like mouthing off like
crazy and if their parents were to hear
them
they'd be like this is this is a
different child right here
it's three things guys
first one
is when we're kids
we're told not to
so
swearing is seen as like this bad thing
don't swear because i don't know about
y'all but i
oh i got smacked with the chunk class so
many times because i i wanted to swear
because i was being told not to swear
and here's the problem when you're told
not to do something
you're probably going to go and do it
unless you are given something else to
do
like
it it's it's in this book that i was
reading
by um
[Music]
lenny bassham
it's called
with a winning in mind it was actually
recommended by
brother faraz zahabi so jazakallah for
um
but in this book he made this example
when someone's playing baseball that's
why i was
doing this motion right here someone's
playing baseball
if he's on his uh
let's say he's got two stripes one more
strike he's out and that's it right
the coach is basically telling him
yo bro
don't strike out
just don't strike out
when this man goes to hit
what do you think is gonna be on his
mind
don't strike out don't strike out don't
strike out so the moment he goes to
swing his whole body is going to react
in a way that's completely aligned with
what he's repeating in his head this
program that he's running in his head
which is
don't strike out so he's gonna strike
out
he's gonna miss the ball but if the
coach would have told him bro all you
gotta do
is hit the ball just hit the ball ah
okay just hit the ball just hit the ball
just
stop and then he hits the ball it's all
the programming is occurring so
in this situation
[Music]
the coach instead of saying don't hit
the ball he's saying or don't strike out
he's saying just hit the ball that's all
you got to do so he's giving him
something better to focus on but with
kids we
i don't know about y'all but i didn't
receive that all i was just told was no
don't curse and then if i did curse i
just got
smacked with the chunkler beating down
with the chunk club bro
so
that's number one
is the fact that we're told not to do it
it's seen as it's like
forbidden fruit
and then when when we curse it's like
did you just curse
and then the little kids would start
like laughing and giggling about it and
then
they'll repeat it even more because
they're like yo we're not supposed to do
this so it's like
they i don't know they they get this
weird little rush from doomy number two
is that we try to fit in
like romney said you got these kids who
they don't curse but then
when they start hanging around these
people and it goes back to like i said
it's our environment it plays a huge
factor
but you go around these people and we
are social beings
so we always try to
connect and kind of fit in into the
social structure whatever social
structure that might be now if you have
this kid and he's going to this new
school he's going
he's starting to talk to these new
people he has a new little click
and they're cursing all the time like
best believe he's probably gonna start
cursing
in order to fit into this group
right it would be no different as if you
had a dude who was cursing all the time
and he went into
an environment where people weren't
cursing he he would eventually stop
cursing
because subconsciously he would want to
fit into this group
and then the third one
is for attention
i mean so ask yourself this people who
are cursing all the time like
why like it has to be none other than
attention
[Music]
that makes sense bro i particularly want
to dive deeper into number two about
fitting in with the group do you guys
remember my theory on why i believe
people love social validation
and why they do too much just to you
know fit in with the group
it's because
we weren't always in civilization you
know comfortable houses with ubereats
and all that we used to live in tribes
and your success and risk of survival
depended directly
on uh if you were in the tribe or not
and a lot of the time when you do things
that stray away from the group group
hive mind the group think
you risk getting kicked out of the tribe
and if you get if you risk getting
kicked out of the tribe you're probably
not going to survive
so that's why it's hard wide in our dna
to want to stay in the tribe
and be like others and fit in
and women particularly
are more subject to groupthink not
because i'm misogynistic
but uh their chances of getting you know
kicked out of the group and surviving
are slim to none compared to us
well they they had to develop that
yeah
didn't they
because you had the men and of course
like
the men
could be kicked out
but the men also
were more resourceful in the hunting
sense
like going out there and hunting for me
and um in the defense
sense like there was another tribe
attacking your tribe like the man was
the one that's gonna defend so
the man had certain elements
there but still the the man still at
risk of being completely shunned out
from the tribe so that's why
men have it as well in our
in our psychology in that subconscious
mindset where it's like
yo we still gotta fit in
but i think women since they had to
develop that over time
i think they have less risk of being
shunned but they also
the downside of that is that now they
they feel
like wanting to fit in even more so
but hey i'm not a woman i can't tell you
that
there's also this aspect of progressive
desensitization to not having haya in
your speech
the first time you say the f word
it's like oh my god did i really just
like nobody i guarantee you this i've
asked people across the world when you
first start swearing a part of your
fitra just doesn't vibe with it you know
you're doing something immoral you know
you're doing something wrong you know
you're doing something allah doesn't
improve of
but the next time you do it doesn't seem
as bad because you've already done it
and then the next time the next time and
before you know it you're not getting
through any lines or words or sentences
without swearing
and then you get into you know this this
dark territory where
it doesn't just change the words you're
saying it's changing how you think as
well
and i think it's a downward slippery
slope and it's a decline that uh society
is going through
and because it's normalized and people
that are at the top
there's a level of idolatry that a lot
of people don't want to admit but look
at your instagram everyone has followers
and those that have more followers are
deemed as more reputable and to be liked
and to be emulated and to be modeled and
these people are swearing of course
you're going to swear you're watching
movies the cool people are swinging of
course you're going to swear but it's
kind of like if society is just going on
a downward slope why follow what they're
doing anyway if we now that we know most
of the things they're doing are not
right
[Music]
yeah yeah 100
i'm glad he mentioned like influencers
and stuff because if you look at like
the most popular ones
um even like streamers and stuff bro
it's it's so hard to find a streamer
that doesn't like swear like crazy uh
again it goes back to like being funny
like something happens in the video game
you're playing and you just like swear
and yell and that freak out that rage is
what people
enjoy watching
um obviously with the swearing and stuff
as well
so it's it's really sad that these are
you know our role models today and these
are you know our
groups
i agree bro i agree it also there's a
there's a whole other element too like
when you start swearing i believe this
is my personal hypothesis that when you
swear
it takes that hijab off it takes that
barrier off it takes that inhibition
away
and then you become victim to more
things like doing things like drugs or
weed no i'm not saying like every time
you swear you consciously you're like
i'm gonna smoke weed today no
but when you lower one inhibition you
lower your general inhibition towards
everything
your unspecified inhibition and then you
go into other things those other things
that further lower your inhibition is
going to make you swear more
and those people that are really
uninhibited
those people that whole group they're
probably swearing on average way more
than
you know those that aren't
and then you're going to fall into group
think and if everyone's swearing i don't
want to be the one that's that's weird
and they're going to think i'm preachy
and saint like so i'm gonna swear too
it goes back to what i said it makes us
less mindful
makes us more absent-minded and this is
like a stain and
supposedly when we sin it's like a stain
and then just
the stain becomes more and more to where
we stop seeing it for what it is and
it's just kind of like
it's ingrained into us and it's it's
normal behavior and then with that stain
it's like you said it's gonna lead this
path
to more sin and more staining of the
heart so it's like bro if you're doing
something that makes you
absent-minded you don't think that
that's gonna
bleed into every other aspect of your
life
like you
you bro our main goal should be to be
more mindful
i don't know if anyone
actually wants to be absent-minded
bro talk to your your your family member
your best friend and just be absent
minded the entire conversation
there's no connection
there's there's nothing there
like read a book and be absent-minded
you'll be on the same line for the next
hour
go outside and be absent-minded you
won't experience anything you'll be
stuck in your heads like no one wants to
be absent-minded but here we are doing
things that make us absent minded
[Music]
tell me this on do you think
being more present makes you more
masculine
of course well
of course
so what you're saying is the thumbnail i
made is not just clickbait that swearing
actually makes you less masculine
i say yeah because it if you're
absent-minded
then
you
you can be controlled very easily
if you're absent-minded
and that's not to say that you can be
controlled just by another person but
you can be controlled by your own
emotions your own desires
as like what's worse than that
what's worse than a dude who you can
make him get angry and then his anger is
controlling him a hundred percent like
i'm sorry but that's not masculine
that's the furthest thing from it
and allah loves those that delay
gratification right those that don't
want those instant dopamine hits i
understand fellas that are watching and
girls that it's cathartic it feels
cathartic
but you might love a thing which is bad
for you and you might hate a thing which
is good for you
so if you're out here swimming and it
feels good and cathartic and you just
can't find that word that that would
just be better suited it's better than
not saying something at all
and i got a question for both of y'all
the prophet sallam said that uh
two of the most difficult things to
control
are what's between your lips and what's
between your legs
your lips between uh your lips meaning
uh your speech and what's between your
legs meaning your sexuality
why do you two think
the first one
is extremely difficult
because you're gonna be very mindful
okay go ahead no no no go on bro like
now you you restarting bro i've already
been talking too much go ahead
no
really detaching from
a lot of social media and then this
these fake personalities online and
these these these fake social networks
it's very beneficial alhamdulillah going
back to the quran sunnah is very helpful
so to go back to the question
i think it's hard because like our
speech is our form of communication our
speech is our main form of telling
people what we're thinking what we're
feeling and a lot of the time when
you're upset
the only way you can communicate that
other than breaking something is by
saying it so i think it's hard to
control our tongues because it's hard to
control our emotions and when we get
emotional if someone angers us if
someone you know does something that we
don't like we want to
all of a sudden put put them down we
want them to know that we don't like
them we want them to feel bad and the
way to make them feel bad other than
like attacking them is verbally by
saying it it's a very passive aggressive
way
to uh to you know
attack someone frankly and that's why a
lot of the time online when you read the
comments on like tik tok and instagram
they're so like messed up
they're so messed up because people like
they they feel some type of way and they
have very very twisted minds and they
will not hold back but those words they
don't come like without a price you know
they're affecting themselves by saying
those things out you know to other
people and they're definitely affecting
other people so i think it's hard to
control it because it's hard to control
how we feel
and our emotional outbreak sometimes i
think the internet is different though
bro because like in the internet there's
really no repercussion
like you know i could type something
and
there's nothing but in person if i say
that thing
i better be ready to back up any
anything that might come with that you
know what i'm saying yeah the internet's
worse in that case then 100
100
but again it
boils down to mindfulness
like it
if you are cursing you are absent-minded
uh whatever you say
whatever you say like whatever comes out
of your mouth even if it's not cursing
it's a direct reflection of your
internal state
right just like harambe said if you're
angry
you're going to verbalize it
if you are happy you are also going to
verbalize now your body language is
going to express it but verbally like we
are verbal creatures so we're going to
verbalize it
when
you speak
if you are absent-minded
then you're basically just going to have
this old programming
that's going to be running
it's it's kind of i'm trying to like
explain the most simple way here but
imagine an npc character
in a video game when you talk to this
npc character
they repeat whatever they were
programmed to repeat
all right when when you are
absent-minded that's what you are you're
an npc character
and you have this old program that's
basically responding for you you
yourself are not responding
this programming that has been
programmed is responding for you
and it's not until you start to become
mindful that you can actually
speak for yourself you can actually
respond to things for yourself actually
stop being an npc and be an actual
character in this game
and
yeah there was something else i was
going to say but i'll be about that
okay so
we talked about swearing we talked about
cursing we talk about profanity all that
and likes
what about back fighting
do you guys have any experience with
backbiting not we're not going to hear
our sins here just for the sake of but
we all come from yeah we all come from
not having the deen intact
thus far i'm not saying we still have
the attack and we're perfect now a lot
of people uh that are in the dms think
we're like no we are flawed we are human
beings we got a long way to go we are
imperfect by all means but
we've still come a long way
from
where we were and where we started and
along the way we learned a thing or two
about backbiting now backbiting why is
it so normalized in today's society why
is everyone just gossiping why do you
see this all this beef and drama and
twitter and all this people just love it
and and you get ingrained into it you
get sucked into it
and what's worse is
i find like i found that it lowers your
masculine energy and your masculinity
because you're talking about someone
behind their back
your sub the sub context is that if they
were there you might not have said it
and you're only saying it there telling
people oh don't tell them that i'm going
to say this don't say this and then you
talk about them behind their back you
know what i mean
yeah once you say
once you see your your part on it
because me and romney have already
spoken
you know i mean what me and romy have
already been speaking too much
so why don't you give your part like
what are your thoughts on that why do
you like when people do that yeah why do
you think people do that
[Music]
i think people have positive thoughts
and negative thoughts right there's not
really anything in between
when we have positive thoughts
this is just what i found for my life
i personally i don't share positive
thoughts much at least back then i
didn't used to share positive thoughts
as much because i was like okay everyone
should be positive i'm positive whatever
when you have negative thoughts you feel
this almost this energy that you want to
vent it out you feel like you want to
you want to release it you want to have
catharsis it's cathartic to vent out
your your frustrations right now what
happens when you're frustrated as
someone
and
i don't know you don't want to just be
uh charged up all day and carry on that
hatred you probably want to let it out
you're probably going to tell someone
that doesn't have anything to do with
that person
and you're probably going to
talk smack about them behind their back
i feel like a huge con a huge
composition of the people that back bite
which is a major sin in islam by the way
um or it could be a minor one don't take
what i'm saying islamically i'm saying
it's like it's a grave sin backbiting is
a gravestone because
um and i feel like a lot of people
backbite because
it's very cathartic it helps you vent it
helps you release your frustration and
it almost feels like you're saying what
you really wanted to say to that person
without actually doing it because if you
do it you don't know what the
consequences would be but you almost get
that dopamine head of saying it it's
kind of like why why people watch p it's
almost like having intimacy without
doing all the hard work
so
we live in a very easy society where
people are lazy so it's no surprise to
me why people backbite
[Music]
um subhanallah i agree 100
i uh
first i want to define backbiting
because a lot of people think backbiting
is slender but slander is not back but
they're not same thing
backbiting is when you say something
about a person behind their back even if
it's true
anything they wouldn't want said about
them anything they wouldn't like
anything that's like negative i guess
um behind their back that they wouldn't
want said um
in general
it's not backbiting if they're there to
defend themselves and all that but if
it's just kind of behind their back then
that is the definition of backbone in
the process
i believe he asked would you want to
to eat the dead flesh or your brother or
maybe it's an ay in the quran
but
regardless it's like eating the the
flesh of your brother um and it's
because you're really you're picking
away at is his social status you're
attacking his honor basically
um
and if you're in yd you know one of the
makassar sharia one of the objectives of
syria is to protect the honor
so you're really really going for it for
their honor and you're ruining them i
guess socially and that has really
serious repercussions
um you know people
become like depressed when they're
kicked out of the tribe basically they
don't have anyone so when you really
strive to ruin that for someone that's a
it's a disgusting thing to be honest and
that's why it's so detestable and also
muslims should have
they should wish the best
for their brothers for their sisters
they should walk for their brothers what
they want for themselves love for their
brothers but they love for themselves
and same thing with the sisters so i
don't think anyone here would want to be
um backbend so we should not go back
fighting others you know there's certain
etiquettes we're supposed to have with
each other as muslims and and imagine
the
entire
social repercussions that are removed uh
from society when people just stop back
biting when they're like oh this is
haram i need to hold my tongue but
people love gossip as you said they love
gossip so much that's why it's why they
watch these really bad reality shows uh
tv shows like like the kardashians and
even hearing about like um celebrity
drama and all that like people love this
stuff and it's so sad you have grown men
and grown women going online and writing
articles about like this person that
person
who cares bro
go live your life man
i agree before anal goes i just want to
give a quick comparison to what rami is
saying about about backbiting anything
that the person wouldn't like that's
what cheating is i get this ass so
commonly and frequently uh people dm me
all the time yo what actually
constitutes cheating
cheating is not you behind your spouse
having intimacy with another spouse
cheating is you doing anything behind
your spouse's back that you wouldn't do
if they were there that's what i define
cheating
i uh
i see where you're coming from and i
agree i just i wouldn't i wouldn't
i wouldn't call someone who like swears
when their partner is around
uh as someone who has intimacy with
another person when their partner is out
i'm talking about it meaning to
pertaining to that person you get what i
mean yeah i just anything you're doing
that affects the other person that
you're with when you're not with them
and you're doing it with someone else
yeah to clarify to clarify is cheating
on your spouse is being anything other
than what you are with them when you're
not with them
yeah that makes sense
yeah yeah and specifically actions and
things that actually affect them for
example if you're texting someone
and you shouldn't be texting them in the
ways that you're texting them and you
wouldn't definitely do that if your
spouse was with you that's that's
cheating bro
yeah not like just you i don't know you
wouldn't lift the weights in front of
your wife and you lift weights when
she's not there that's not cheating
don't take what i'm saying now and
you get out of context yeah
what i mean is
there's those levels to it and i
wouldn't i wouldn't
because like even islamically like
committing zinna is punishable you know
by stoning
if you have the correct witnesses and
everything
and um if the person testifies it like
that's that's it um and i just
all i'm trying to say is i wouldn't call
the person the example you gave
the same title as the person who
committed zinna you know what i mean
like there's there's a there's a range
but it's all haram it's all wrong it's
all like detestable 100
yeah i agree i agree
yeah
and to add on to y'all's point
it kind of goes back to what we were
saying
about the whole tribe thing we're trying
to fit in
people
really gossip because they're trying to
fit in
and sometimes the way that they try to
fit in
is they they just try to have
conversation they just try to say
something so i was like
i had this in the past
you know i mean i'm not going to hear my
sins but i had this in the past where
any time i'd be around people
like i wanted to connect with them
i wanted to be a part of like that whole
group tribe whatever it is
but i didn't know what to say
you know i was kind of
just kind of shy and awkward and just to
myself
for
a very big part of my life
and
unfortunately backbiting is
i think it's one of the easiest things
it's one of the easiest things to say
where like everyone's gonna just like
jump on it and then it's like you got
this person
um adding to the the fire
and then it's like oh well now you feel
like you're connected because you're
both adding and it's it's fake it's not
real it's not a real connection because
like i've seen it firsthand and i i
still see it till this day where i see
other people
backbiting and they feel like
they're getting this connection
that they're looking for but
if only they knew that it would actually
be better for them to not backbite it
would be better for them to not gossip
you know like
geez i know people close to me and again
i'm not going to say any names so i
don't want to throw anyone on blast but
they still backbite and i tell them like
yo like let's talk about something
different
and then like we'll talk about something
different and they don't go right back
to back but i'm like yo
chill out
i don't know if you notice this
but you keep going back to talking bad
about someone
and they're like stop and they're like
either they'll reflect on it or they'll
try to like cut me off and be like oh
like why are you trying to tell me how
to act i'm like listen i'm just i'm
exposing the truth here that's all i'm
doing mm-hmm
don't don't hate me for having a fitra
guys you know what i mean it's one of
them ones
bro you're on a roll so i'm gonna ask
you a physics question right now
physics
101 physics hold up boy all right if we
study no physics 100 viewers in the chat
right now
how many likes should we have on the
stream right now minimum 100 200 there
you go i don't know how he did that i
don't even know the physics formula he
used but mashallah man
we got the king right here but
seriously guys smash that like button if
you want to see an actual take about
backbiting from a sheikh
let's see what he has to say is
[Music]
i wanted to talk to you all inshaallah
today about a very serious issue the
issue of backbiting
allah in the quran in suratul
number 49 which is like the surah of
etiquette the surah of adam in ayah
number 12 allah
starts off by saying
o you who believe all those people who
have claimed faith have claimed iman
and see something very interesting is
that every single place in the quran
where allah says
he's either then afterwards either
telling us to do something or he's
forbidding us from something because
when allah says
saying that you've claimed that you
believe
now here's a chance an opportunity for
you to prove whether you are actually a
believer or not if you are a true
sincere believer then you will do the
following if you are a true or sincere
believer then you will not do the
following so here allah tells us
language means stay away from something
abstain from something all right and
what's very fascinating about this is
another place in the quran where allah
uses the word idjanibu to tell us to
stay away from something he says
stay away from alcohol
stay away from gambling the word that
allah uses to tell us to stay away from
drinking wine and gambling is the word
ijtanibu so think about the gravity of
it and think about the association that
what follows after this word is so bad
you need to completely stay away from it
it's completely haram
absolutely unequivocally haram forbidden
you can't do it
so whatever allah is saying here in
surah 49 ayah 12 is about to be very
very serious well what does he say
stay away from most assumptions don't
assume things about people stay away
from most assumptions why innaban
because some assumptions are sinful
allah teaches us something here when
when something is so problematic it's
sometimes better to stay away from it
all together so allah says stay away
from most types of assumptions because
some assumptions are very bad in the
moon
now allah tells us why what's so
terrible about assumptions because
you're assuming something on someone's
behalf of what makes it worse because it
leads to other bad things that's why
allah uses the word
ism is a type of sin the sin of the
heart and the type of sin that leads to
other sins because it's in the heart so
allah says
don't spy on people don't spy when you
start assuming things about people you
become suspicious of people then you
want to confirm your suspicion so you go
snooping around poking into people's
business creeping and stalking right
trying to confirm your suspicions about
people well
don't spy on people don't creep on
people don't stalk people then allah
says once you start spying and creeping
and stalking people guess what you might
be able to confirm some of your
suspicions and you find out oh my god he
is doing this oh my god she is doing
that now you start now you confirm some
of your suspicions you know what happens
when you have a juicy piece of
information like that you develop the
worst stomach ache that you've ever had
in your entire life because you have to
now tell somebody about this you have to
talk to somebody you have to text
somebody you have to tell somebody you
have to message somebody you have to put
it on facebook you have to put it on
twitter you got to tell somebody
until you don't tell somebody that thing
is going to start causing you stomach
pains and stomach aches
that and so what happens you go to
somebody and you tell them hey listen
i'm gonna tell you something
but please don't tell anybody promise to
me you won't tell anybody which is
basically code for right after i'm done
telling you make sure you go tell
somebody just like i told you
it's called backbiting
[Music]
some of you should not backbite about
others what is the definition of riba
backbiting so the prophet salallahu
it is you saying something about
somebody else that they would not
appreciate you saying the companion
asked the prophet salallahu well what if
what i'm saying is true
what if i'm what i'm saying is true the
prophet salallahu said then that is the
very definition of backbiting if what
you're saying about that person isn't
true that's slander that's an even
bigger crime and even a bigger issue but
saying something that somebody else
would not appreciate you saying about
them
is the definition of backbiting so allah
says don't backbite one another and then
allah gives us an example
he presents a parable an example an
image to us in the quran
and i'm going to go ahead and let you
all know here real quick a disclaimer
this is one of the most graphic images
that is presented to us in the entire
quran
now let's take a look at what allah is
telling us
would any one of you like would any one
of you love
and now allah uses the word you hibbu
right to love something would you love
to do the following
any one of you
right because allah is saying think
about you doing this yourself
to eat the flesh
of his or her own sibling brother or
sister brother sibling would any one of
you love to eat the flesh the meat of
his brother maitan that is dead
corpse the word mate in the arabic
language means a corpse already dead
so now here let me talk this out to you
let me explain to you real quick what
this basically means is that imagine
somebody's brother imagine your brother
or your sister your sibling died may
allah protect all of us and our family
members but imagine your sibling died
and their body is laying there in front
of you and you're sitting next to their
body crying and mourning their loss
you're crying and you're sad that you've
lost your brother your sister your
sibling
and then all of a sudden
you reach down you pick them up pick up
their hand or
go to their leg and you
chew you take a bite out of them
and you start to chew and eat their
flesh
the corpse the body of your dead sibling
how graphic how disgusting how crazy
is that image is that idea
allah says would any one of you love to
do that
and allah says
of course you would hate that
you you hate just hearing about it just
talking about it just listening to it
just reading about it makes your skin
crawl
that's how disgusting it would be
similarly
allah says is the example of when you
backbite somebody that's just as
disgusting of an act now i'm going to
answer a question real quick right here
the quran is the speech of god the word
of allah guidance and mercy and rahma
from allah
nude and hidayah from allah why would
allah give us such a disgusting image in
the quran
because when you picture that in your
head and it makes you jump backwards
it's so disgusting it shakes you to your
core
allah wants us to feel disgusted because
he's saying just as disgusting
as that would be somebody eating the
flesh of their own dead sibling
it is even more disgusting when you
backbite about somebody when you violate
someone's dignity someone's honor
someone's respect and you talk about
them that's even more disgusting than
that
allah takes it a step further
actually i want you to think about this
for a second further you know a lot of
times there's the question i don't back
by anybody but what if somebody else is
are you a party to that are you
entertaining that are you
there while they're doing it and
therefore giving them a sympathetic ear
you're becoming a part of this by
listening to it so let's look at the
example the example the quran the
examples the quran gives are so powerful
and eloquent because there's so many
angles and features to this
can you imagine
if you if it's not your sibling somebody
else's brother dies somebody else's
sister dies and that person's
sib
siblings dead body their brother and
sister's dead body is lying there
and they reach down and start to eat and
chew and devour the dead body of their
own brother or sister
would you sit there and would you watch
if you were there the third party if you
were there you're not the one doing it
but if you were there what would you do
you would stop that person you tell them
don't do that that's gross that's
disgusting that's terrible what are you
doing
and if you could not stop them
at the very least you would run from
there you would leave there you wouldn't
sit there and keep watching and be like
oh okay i'm just gonna mind my own
business
no you would run from that place when
somebody else backbites don't be a party
to it don't listen to it if you have the
type of relationship where you can
gently kindly nicely say please don't do
that please let's not talk about
somebody then remind them and in fact if
they won't listen to you or you can't
tell them that then at the very least
change the topic change the subject get
up and walk away go busy yourself with
something else but don't be a party to
that because that's like sitting there
and watching somebody eat
their own dead siblings body that's how
disgusting it is
and always think of allah whether
somebody else hears you or not whether
somebody else sees you or not whether
somebody will know about this
conversation or not allah knows allah
watches allah hears allah sees
so be think about allah be conscious of
allah and then finally allah says
look none of us are perfect
i've made this mistake y'all have
probably made this mistake as well in
the past allah tells us
no worries if you've done it in allah
allah is extremely extremely forgiving
like he accepts our repentance
all we got to do is say oh allah i'm
sorry i messed up
go and apologize to the person i'm sorry
for saying bad things about you
and allah is extremely merciful allah
mercy will welcome you with open arms
allah will accept you into his mercy and
allah will put mercy in your heart and
allah will put mercy in the heart of the
person when you go to apologize to them
so don't worry if you've messed up just
ask allah for forgiveness and ask allah
for his mercy
and a really cool story just to kind of
close things off
who's a great scholar a great tabi and a
student of the sahaba
a real boss he said something really
awesome one time
he said that
somebody came and told him you know that
guy he's backbiting about you he goes
around talking to everybody and saying
bad things about you he said okay he yo
i love this story but uh what's going on
with it put together a nice little gift
he packaged together a nice little gift
and he gave it to his assistant his
student and he said here take this gift
and please go deliver it to that person
and he gave him a note along with it he
wrote a note and he gave it gave him the
note along with it when that person goes
to that person who's been backbiting
about al-hasan basri and he gives him
the gift and he's like al-hasan al-basri
has sent you this gift and he's like
really why just out of the blue he sent
this note along with this gift when he
opened the note and he read it the note
said that
since you have been backbiting about me
and therefore gifting me all your good
deeds i thought i should repay the favor
and give you a gift as well
when you back bite somebody else
you give your good deeds away to that
person so just something to think about
and if somebody's back biting you
just know they're giving you their good
deeds and that should be more than
enough comfort and solace for you
i just want to add something to that the
point of repentance that guys there was
a sister on instagram that she wrote a
caption she wrote
instead of asking yourself what if allah
doesn't forgive me have you ever asked
yourself just once
what if allah does love me
what if allah did forgive me
[Music]
i really like everything exciting man
and there's one thing that i do as well
that i know this works pretty well
is if someone's backbiting
say something really good about the
person they're backbiting
they just
they can't continue they get angry they
either want to like end the conversation
or they completely like change their
stance and like yeah you know what
you're right i shouldn't be saying
something like that they're actually
really good people you know maybe
and i would say well
i'll give you an example of somebody
that did that in real time yesterday and
practically applied what angel said a
brother by the name of muhammad i'm sure
nobody here knows him because you know i
didn't even know who mohammed hijab was
um muhammad hijab he had an episode with
jordan peterson i'm just being facetious
guys he's a huge uh force in the dawah
he had an episode of jordan peterson
scheduled and jordan peterson canceled
it
as muhammad hijab is saying this in his
quick two three minute video announcing
the cancellation of the of the episode
he further repeats and says the line
nobody go onto his social media
and hate him
and spam him
and write comments that are that are
negative because you don't know what
he's going through
despite jordan peterson cancelling three
times
for muhammad hijab he said guys don't
write this because he could be having a
mental health crisis he could be having
things that he doesn't want to air out
in public
and you don't want to represent the
muslims in a negative way
just think about how powerful that is
he in what he's saying knowing it might
trigger you to think about about someone
negatively
he tells you to not think of it
negatively and think of him positively
may allah
[Music]
that's some serious stuff bro
sometimes it takes a lot to
have someone like
that's close to you talking about
someone else and then for you to just
tell them like look like let's let's not
talk about let's not talk about this
person let's not talk about that
you know what while you keep talking bro
i'm just gonna make the chat public now
instead of members only i'm good i don't
have anything else to say
actually i do have something to say so a
lot of people
that are in this uh conundrum
or maybe they are a backbone maybe they
are slamming maybe that is a way of
connecting with people maybe they feel
like
they don't know what to say when they're
with other people
a good thing to
then their focus on
would be to speak about ideas
you know
like instead of speaking about people
why not speak about ideas
why not speak about like something that
you're reading about or like just
something really interesting you know
i'm saying like that changes the whole
dynamic of the conversation
[Music]
i agree
yeah
what is this
all righty next we got a question from
i'm not going to read that whole name
guys talk about hadith bankrupt and
maybe four hadith pillars of manners by
jack hamza
inshallah
it is imperative to remind everyone to
never backblade
he said it's imperative to remind your
wife yeah i'm correct always non-big
bite okay
all right what's the name of that check
i'm gonna put the link in the
description guys because
he was good bro yeah he's on the
platform uh
i think quran weekly 600k subs norman
ali khan is uh is in that deep so
inshallah
well
first i'm catching you bros live from
dubai
what time is it over there 11 41 a.m
what time is it in dubai
dubai should be seven hours ahead if if
i'm correct
so it should be 6 41
p.m
islam
my salon to everybody who's saying
assalamu alaikum there we go
all right now we're just going to keep
saying it over and over from nora
my non-muslim friend always black but
it's about people we used to go to
school with
that's half of our conversation most of
the time
that's why i'm reluctant to meet him
these days i don't know what's your take
on that take control of that
conversation yeah
try what i said where
when the bag bites
say something good about the person
watch just watch just watch just watch
let's do it do it and see for yourself
are you all married now
one yes
another one getting there and then the
other one
i don't even know where that one is and
y'all interpret who
they
is
sister
salaam alaikum welcome to the chat uh
lego my
you're women on toys but men act like
women these days
do you hold back your left arm
i don't think i do to be honest
i think it's because i don't laugh like
out loud i kind of just like have air
come up my nostrils and like smile or
something
[Music]
okay remember questions from us
everybody in the chat something to you
why i like islam thought it was a
question but uh
said the same one
okay question not question statement
from uh
backbiting is allowed in one case when
someone's life is in danger
why
how
i'm gonna have to fact check that but uh
yeah
why don't you
explain how explain that write it write
us a comment
us if we're ignorant
starting from toronto there we go
that's your own parents saying negative
things about their families that's uh
oh yeah
but try try that thing just
say say good things about the family
members
love from kashmir and subhanallah
i'm the one that's on the way
yo what's up yo who who's lil queasy
who's this little queasy everyone keeps
talking about
i don't know man that guy died a long
time ago yeah
i'm gonna protect that guy bro i don't
know where he is oh the ego bro
sister maria from germany salaam alaykum
australia is still in lockdown bro tell
me that's not crazy yeah wow but they
have the least cases of covert if i'm
not mistaken
i guess they don't want that to change
apparently apparently
wow uh we we filmed an episode with dr
steph karis
uh a world-renowned historian martial
mayor bless him on hijrah please watch
that episode
i've heard that it is not backbiting if
it is an inquiry for marriage
or give me a little bro yeah
in what sense like
i don't understand
let's ask the self-improvement king this
question
[ __ ] wants to start on this
[Laughter]
i know so confident he's like yo that's
me i was just reading it bro
i'm playing broco
uh
start right now
start with whatever you feel that you
need to start on
i don't know what that's gonna look like
for you
but just start right now
yeah
100
hairline
that's my hairline we got a hair review
right there
y'all seen me in the past videos i just
it's cold as hell appeared right now
never last again or says again it is not
about cover anymore tyrannical control
of some people uh we're not gonna talk
about you know the the sea virus over
here
but what we did do is we filmed an
episode
going deep into uh
all of this
and
uh
stuff you do with your arm putting
something in there
and it's on patreon
episode 61 why not find that out it's on
patreon because
it's flagged and removed here so what
can we do
appreciate it
yes preach
although i don't think that's the real
name of junior i heard that
i heard that when i used to work at uh
this supplement so i'm not gonna say any
names um i wasn't backbiting but i
remember the customer came in
and he was asking me something at the
time i was very absent-minded remember
how i said if you're absolutely like an
npc character so i was just going on
talking talking talking talking and then
at the end he just stayed real quiet
he's like
we have two ears
and one mouth
do you guys know the guy with the puffy
hair who does no fat um you're talking
about um
i am lucid
i am lucid i actually know the brother
personally
and um i'll leave it like that
but we'll see if we'll invite
that's a joke
ain't nothing much to it
there's not much to it i'll tell you
that
oh i think there's narcia
isn't it in this case
um
yeah i mean warning someone about
someone else is not bad like i think
this is what the person was saying about
marriage like for example if your friend
comes to you if you know something about
someone like someone's a drug addict and
your friend comes to you like oh should
i marry that person they don't know he's
a drug addict you're allowed to say like
no don't because he's a drug addict
that's why even with like talking about
your sins if you're going to seek advice
like hey
i did this i don't know what to do you
know
what should i do um it's okay to to say
what you did or at least be general
about it
um but there are ways around this if you
want to be safe to say listen
say listen i know this person i know
things about them i'm not going to say
it trust me don't marry them if they
trust you enough they won't
i don't even know i don't know he's
debating uh yeah it's a debate bro david
wouldn't know
we're not going to react to that because
danny
miller bless him bro but i've seen some
seven to nine hour streams and i was
like bruh
has it really been seven to nine hour
streams
he's absent-minded
i can see that
genetics
what are you talking about genetics from
what
oh the bu
oh yeah
yeah you can still groom it the way you
want but
having a full beard for sure i'd say is
genetic
yeah to an extent
because you can use minoxidil and the
microneedling
and that leaves permanent results but
i've never done it so i can't speak 100
on it
no i'm palestinian everyone thinks i'm a
different because my name is rami but
i'm palestinian alhamdulillah
you're good
i think that's on islamic bro
yeah i like that
what's not her
yeah
yeah i mean that doesn't change the fact
that she's in that position yeah i know
yeah
i'm just trying to say like don't feel
obligated by allah
yeah
but if if you're gonna carry on to do so
oh i'd say to
keep making time for yourself
keep those
like little
feminine practices and all that stuff
you know because that that'll keep you
[Music]
on track with everything
and don't close yourself off to
having someone
take over
like if you meet a brother
and like this brother's gonna be
basically it's gonna take over for you
and all that stuff
like don't be so against that because
that's the that's the worst thing is
that when women start to go more to
their masculine side
they're more
willing to
push
a man to the side
because they feel like they got it
you know and
you don't want that
yeah which deodorant do i use are you
serious bro
i'll not know i also want to say don't
feel so desperate that you kind of run
into a marriage either be careful of
that
if i was the last time you visited
bangladesh 2009 buddy actually no 2011
been 10 years
oh
look at that
i mean
can we get the brand bro
it's um
i took the sticker off but you can get
it
literally the the brand name is crystal
oh mashaallah
and it's literally just a crystal
that's kind of
it works really good
we got another question for you too bro
how many wives do you wanna
listen
i'm gonna put my desires to the side and
just say
i'll accept whatever a lot gives me
whether that be zero or whether that be
four whether it be one two three
whatever allah has
decreed my desires don't even matter at
the end of the day
i think that's
unless your voice is naturally
there like
why
like
except what allah has given you as if i
even said this in my video
on how to get a deeper voice i tell
people look like this is only going to
bring your voice to his natural depth
and if you don't have a deep voice then
you should still just accept what you
have
because
each tone is different
50 000 likes on this stream and we will
reveal the app that angel uses to get
that deep voice on all of his recordings
50 000
i mean i'm i'm not using it right now so
but guys just think about the the codics
people who recite the quran like not all
of them have deep voices
and you see how beautiful it is
the different tones of the voices so
like why would you only want to have
this deep tone it's because something
someone said to you
it's like ah having a deep voice is
being masculine
bro please and like what is this
oh man i'm dying bro please
yes sir he's the the silver muslim right
now boy
y'all heard about the silver surfer now
this is silver muslim i'm still a muslim
bro i feel i feel you know physically on
point mentally i don't really feel on
point right now because i feel like
intellectually i'm lacking what
mongolian throat singing is somebody
please let us know in the chat right now
somebody googled that
i think it's when they they they sing
with their throat and they have two
different tones like a deep tone and a
high tone it sounds
[Laughter]
yeah some please do it because i might
be mistaken but when i i don't know when
you left i just added to your point
because the you you told the sister like
don't be afraid to get married and i
said at the same time don't don't feel
desperate like you really want someone
to take over and then kind of run to
anyone so rushing to marriage is just
like i mean like
like you find someone okay like i'm not
gonna get to know you i'm just gonna
jump into it it might work but
be careful
that's fine i don't think anno is making
any video
anytime soon probably not
give some general advice bro
i actually had the next video that i was
gonna make supposedly i was gonna make
it like two two weeks ago still haven't
made it but um it was actually going to
be on nofap it was uh the thing that
they don't tell you about nofap so
look out for that one inshallah not
gonna lie bro that uh the mongolian
throat scene got me slipping out of my
masculine frame
rami why don't you answer this first
buddy
well i mean our palettes are probably
very different i honestly eat like a lot
of rice and trick and that's
honestly mainly what it might my uh
diet consists of
no for no specific reason get us 1500
likes on the stream we'll do a full day
yeah that'd of
dope um
i try
to just eat whole foods
so it'll it'll consist of um
those things basically humming oh god
you got you got you i try to eat whole
foods so like you got the meats you got
the fruits
a little bit of vegetables not too much
sometimes i'll do something like
some nuts
um
[Music]
honey
and
[Music]
yeah some white rice here and there i
don't really do like grains like oatmeal
bread and stuff like that and i'm not
gonna lie i'm not perfect
because um there are times where
you get some doughnuts in front of you
you get some baklava you just get some
good stuff and you just you gotta go and
go you gotta go in
why are you fighting
oh this is poor man i'm on a strict uh
seafood diet bro
oh you seafood and you eat it how did
you know bro
brother ah enough salam hijab and jvp
are going to be talking soon bro i don't
know if you've seen it but muhammad
dropped the video yesterday saying that
it's cancelled i don't know if he
reverted on that decision and they're
actually going to do it but i believe jp
uh has canceled that but correct me if
i'm wrong my thoughts on him with regard
to addressing jbps i think it's
necessary i think there's been a lot of
uh i don't even want to say information
but misinformation about islam spread by
people that he has on the channel and i
think it's finally good to have a
traditionalist muslim on the channel to
clarify and clear our name so
being a force in the dawah
talking about muhammad hijab someone
like him very necessary in a big
platform like that it's kind of like the
equivalent of phase apex
unapologetically conveying that he's
muslim to the world
[Music]
are you guys going to talk to i'm lucy i
don't know who that is bro
i don't know
oh you know
yeah i had had his contact so i'll hit
him up with him
by the way bro
he's a brother or a brother okay
you sound like he likes lucid dreaming
or something no that's his youtube
channel name
okay
okay guys we're gonna wrap this up in a
few minutes last couple of questions
actually about
guys i'm gonna give you like two minutes
and i'm all yeah we'll wrap it up in two
minutes okay
what is the book that you have benefited
from in terms of the most in terms of
knowledge other than the quran
bro where can i get this
amazon bro really marshall
i'm just going to get it
there's no discount code bro
but you can get all the uh can
yeah you can get that too this has all
the volumes um it's short too because
there's no repeat of the hadith it's
just like every single hadith wants yeah
oh by the way what about you guys what
are your favorite books aside from the
quran i mean
i know you want to answer that first i
was answering the
comment that yeah they put it
oh as as of now i'd say the
uh alchemy of happiness but i'm not even
like
that far in i'm only like
like second chapter
but i got i got to pick up the hadith
books for real for real
yeah yeah you guys remember the episode
we did with uh free actually we don't
have time
yeah i was just gonna i was just gonna
say be careful like when you read hadith
certain ones like when you get to the
less authentic ones be careful because
then you're like it's authentic i don't
know be careful with that stuff and
always you know go to a scholar for
interpretation and stuff but for me i'm
just going to say this because i
honestly unfortunately i don't read much
in sha allah i'm working on that um
i think it was a book called
something like that it's talking about
the progression of a nation
um if you want to reach out to me it's
really really interesting on how you
rate the progression of a nation and all
of that um because people rate it based
on like oh we have this many graduates
of university this many jobs and they
don't rate it based on how
united the people are with the
government and how much they love and
care about each other
[Music]
all right
inshallah one day
all right so me and romney will stay
this time one or two more minutes bonnie
your
i love blessed that brother
i mean
we're
from in palestine bro
i mean
i mean i mean i'm from
i like the name
mashallah
i mean
i mean
episode coming out on friday live player
with such an ema on red pill and islam
and
should we trust women should we really
trust women are muslim women actually
above
female nature are they just holier are
they better are they immune to the nufs
and desires that women have
stay tuned for friday
yeah also it's not your job to reclaim
his faith it's something he has to work
on just kind of lead him guide him there
he probably went through a heartbreak
with one or two women maybe three
they're bad women they're good women
just he has to see that child a lot
sister why are you referring to the one
with
written by dr omar zed
i like that bro i like i mean cis i like
that too but let me know if that's the
answer
they've been doing that bro they i know
who the the modules and the templars are
but the the west has been doing that
since like
the renaissance man they've been doing
that for a while bro
rami this one's for you
my feminist sister thinks feminism is
then what should i do proof just show
terror that's not very clearly shorter
that it's not go to the the books of the
mother
and the founding mothers of feminism and
show them exactly what they said and
then show them how they committed kuffar
on feminism
what's up i said do you mean the
founding fathers of feminism well there
are there are women i mean the the the
original woman
there is no one
originally yeah there were men but i'm
talking when it was a hijacking when it
was it was changed up
uh different women took those roles and
they were some of them are still being
led by a man to even in even within
those roles but um
just prove to her that it's not
hey there you go real recognize real
mashallah
oh this is a good one
dalton nicholas might be a genuine
question
author of sahih bukhari is imam imam
bukhari he's named imam bukhari because
he's from i believe bukhara it's the
place he's from and his real name i
think is muhammad ibn ibrahim or ibn
ibrahim
israel ibrahim something like that
he is the com compiler of the
compilation of you know sahih al-bukhari
but
essentially they were just sayings of
the prophet saws
just want to be specific on that
yeah one little piece of information he
was so so strict with the types of a
hadith he let in not based on just what
was said but based on the chain of
narration if it was authentic if it was
if it was you know
historically accurate i guess you could
say
that's why
it's authentic
let me try and find it for you inshallah
i think it's called uh
al nakhaba or something like that i'll
find it
i mean originally from pakistan or
bangladesh the left one
well it depends on uh
which way you have your screen turned
for left if you're talking about rami
he's not from pakistan or bangladesh
talking about me i'm from bangladesh i'm
from dhaka
i found the name of the books called
yeah
all right we got
one more minute harami what about this
one
breath
mommy just froze
the vast majority of them are muslim
alhamdulillah but i do believe they are
off the right path i think there is a
few issues with their akida and with
their
um texts
but they're muslim
a rational believer they have a place
called the army of satan one of the
episodes explosives feminism that guy
slash girl should let the sister watch
it we're going to react to some of the
it's a good series mashallah
this is also sent this sentence this in
the dm's i didn't really know how to
answer that what does pink islam wrote
you know pink islam i think i know what
they're talking about i think there was
this movement
to
print these like pink covered copies of
the quran with certain verses removed
and i think it's just the like a group
of i think women trying to just change
islam completely
if that's the case haram
disbelief hellfire may allah protect us
from that
yeah i believe modifying the words of
allah saying something that's
not
saying something's haram that's actually
this is a sin worse than [ __ ] guys this
is not a light thing to change what
allah's religion is so
stay away from that may allah protect us
i mean
i mean and yeah it's supposed to be
progressive
i was just saying like i just looked it
up it's supposed to be like a
progressive islam
islam's timeless there's no progression
in that it's already perfect how do you
progress from something perfect
exactly
you know abu bakr
he cried when the verse was revealed the
verse that says today i perfected
your religion and completed my favor
upon you or complete my favorite upon
you perfected your religion he cried
because he knew the only thing that
comes after perfection is is the like
the basically coming down it's only done
exactly exactly yeah are you guys
introvert or extrovert uh i'm both i
don't mean where were you yeah i was
gonna say the same exact thing like i
feel like i can't classify as one it's
just
i'm both bro
okay if that's it last three more
questions and then we're done this
stream
rami what time is drama in mississauga
they have one from one to one thirty
another one from three to three thirty i
believe um
okay
another one at 3 15.
okay
first out of the three
final ones
um if you okay listen bro if if you're
saying that like bold statement she
compromises my hera you're not going to
be able to live with that bro if you are
claiming that now that she compromises
your hera you're not going to be able to
live with that as a man it's going to
break your marriage
in time you're going to grow with her
and you're going to be like you know
what
i don't want you to have instagram
anymore and then some fighting's gonna
ensue because she's gonna feel like
and trust me take it from me bro she's
gonna be like you know at the beginning
you're fine with it why are you changing
now and it's gonna be this issue if you
don't like it make it clear if she's not
willing to to change it then
marry someone else
mashallah so why this is not a question
but i had to uh put it up there and pin
it for the for the whole squad this is
very important that you guys know this
stuck for allah this is not islam
yeah
female prophet bro that's like that's
the equivalent of
women having an issue that allah uses he
as in the masculine pronoun
some women recently actually had a
problem with that
it's it's it's very ignorant
this is why we need more daddies
especially the female sisters
to challenge these uh
nonsensical people
yes sister said it best martial
inshallah sister rod will find your way
bro
i'm gonna put the link in the
description
i had these that i could think of right
now that i'm not
uh
too familiar with if this is the one i'm
gonna use but i'll put the link in the
description anyway after i uh do this
but the hadith was where uh fatima uh
may not be pleased with her
was uh complaining about you know doing
stuff and she wanted a maid and uh the
prophet saws said that don't you know
that there's something better for you
don't you know that you should say
subhanallah
like just
he didn't give her a maid
but i think i wanna okay
first when did you when did you say this
did you say this stream because i must
have been very upset i didn't see it in
this stream i watched a video by sajid
lipham where he said that that it's a
woman's obligation and responsibility to
take care of the house and it's a man's
responsibility and obligation
to provide
i see i see uh one the one thing i want
to add about the hadith because i
actually heard it um
the prophet saws i think there was more
context he didn't gave give her a maid
it's not that he didn't want to or he
thought it was better if she took care
of her own health it's because he had a
group of poor people who migrated for
his sake they migrated into poverty and
he gave all his resources to those
people so he said if i hadn't made i
would i'll delegate it to them
that's what he's saying um but i just
wanted to add that little piece of
context
i don't know if this is satire
i don't confirm more than i do
okay last question
supportive husband i mean support comes
in many forms one financially he's
obligated to support you two
um emotionally is a bit of like a
it's a bit of an off one because there
isn't like a you know guidelines for
that there aren't really borders for
that or a specific way of doing it but
um being nice and being there for your
partner is basically an obligation uh so
you do have to have some kind of you
know moral emotional support um uh he
has to be a husband uh like as a as a
leader he has to be a leader and i think
that is him supporting you by leading
you correctly as islamically he's
obligated to he has he's given authority
where he's given responsibility and i
think that's the definition of support
him being a good husband and leading you
to jannah inshallah
mashallah
all right with that being said rami
i think that's it let's do your thing
friday for you guys and you haven't gone
to drama yet go to jamaa it's obligatory
for men
if you're a woman
it's not obligatory if it's already been
jammed and you went mashallah if you
didn't go let's try again next week
there's another thing too it's it's the
perseverance aspect too like we're more
willing to stick through with things
that we set out with an intention it's
impossible to have empathy for others if
you're not patient so my love bless you
for that first of all i'm gonna agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm